hi you guys i am coming on the road get
tickets at esther on ice.com i'm coming
to new york florida i'm coming to san
francisco portland you guys know where
to go esther on ice.com for tickets and
go to sleepoverbyaster.com to check out
the new drop
that is so cute we have now we have 100
recycled t-shirts so nobody can tell me
i'm a bad person well you still can but
it'll be harder hello sluggies i
am back on tour you can see me this
weekend august 27th and 28th at the
hartford funny bone in connecticut
september 7th and 8th at the zany's in
chicago cleveland ohio at hilarity
september 9th through 11th the life is
beautiful festival in las vegas new
nevada uh september 18th and 19th
rayleigh north carolina at goodnight
september 23rd through 25th can't wait
to see you guys it's been absolutely
amazing
all right i missed you this episode but
i will see you on the next and esther
does touch my vagina so you're gonna
want to see that one
[Music]
kala has a pair of underwear that was
mine well that's weird to share that
[ __ ] why does she have your old
underwear that she seems weird it was a
gift um two years ago on my birthday is
my teeth you gifted her old underwear
she gifted me her panties from when she
was school high school yeah
are you jealous yesterday wait i am
because i feel like that i know what
they are and i want them because they
are they're the ones with the band
they're blue and white
here i've always wait you give me a pair
like that ones these were superman right
so okay and they had a hole in them like
probably where i had been scratching my
vagina
okay also one thing i was you know one
thing i was thinking on the way over
here is your instagram handle is jenna
jumenez
did i
i really think i don't wanna i
i i think i gave you that name
and you gave me esther monster which is
going to give you you might have given
me i think i was the first person to say
jenna j i want to go ahead and say um
you name um donut as well i sure did
yeah yeah we were all sitting there
we're like it should be a it should be a
dessert and everyone was naming desserts
and then jenna said donut and i was like
that's it also though she's the only
person who's been able to submit julio
julio we have a weird dog named julio oh
i was just thinking of a guy in high
school who named julio who once made fun
of me for wearing glitter eyeshadow and
it just you just triggered it so i'm
just gonna did you fight back come on no
i no but this is my moment julio you
were wrong actually you were right
glitter eyeshadow is lame
no there aren't many redeemable julios
because my dog julio is quite the
monster except i think jenna broke him
because
um you humped him back one time yeah
sure what
it's like my thing
no no no no
no no like it's a training what
technique that i made up okay like tell
us because the dog that's that's it like
when a dog is humping you what are you
uh leo is a troubled dog how he likes no
one so show me like if i'm the dog okay
like let's see look first i'm gonna hump
you yeah just come up like on my leg
that's how you hump that is the problem
yes i did
yes i did i grabbed him and went
and then it was like everything was fine
ever since then he's just like he cr
like what
he bends the knee when he's when he said
hi to me yesterday he did a thing where
he twisted his body
and he was like
why
he's weird he does yoga poses he's um
you know he's uh so he's our
neighborhood sociopath the best
behaviorist in l.a
looked me dead in the eyes and said
nothing can be done
what
he basically said do you still have this
stuff yeah we love him so much he's the
best i can't julio
julia insane oh really yeah yeah also if
you want to know what it's like when
george trains a dog that's just how he
talks to me and annie
he's like okay good girl
is it a bad girl don't be a bad girl oh
let's not do that
do you like money
that's amazing yeah
every time i have a complaint of any
sorts kalila do you like money
too
yes
that's the only way to get us to fall
back in line very quickly i know we're
so that would make me fall back in line
real fast so okay
let's give the audience proper
information jenna is you're like look
like you're like about to have sex or
something like how is this sex like
how you imagine her
attack dave after you humped me i'm like
that's how you have sex
um jenna is my
best friend
we went to college together it's kind of
a big deal best friends so many memories
it's a very big deal i think jenna is
your biggest contribution to my life
my wait that was a lot of smart words my
biggest your biggest contribution to my
life is introducing her to me that's
actually rude
i'm actually kind so upset that's sweet
the sweetest thing and most no
compassionate kind thing anyone has ever
said about me no that is so rude second
to your love and presence it's actually
the kindest thing anyone's ever said
about you even though
i get it i'm still really offended
but yes i do get it when someone because
jenna won't just like take anyone on she
doesn't take new clients on often i've
been getting rid of clients actually i
remember when like
five or six years ago you're like esther
no new friends like i just can't and i
was like okay good to know and she you
have a
big when i met you
giant bank of friends i used to think
like well and i understood it you're a
beloved person yeah anyone who meets you
people are addicted to you yeah that's
so sweet and also i would say like
you're the friend i think we have this
with each other where it's like when
[ __ ] like just
tell if there's something that you're so
humiliated that you never would tell
anyone you tell me and i tell you yeah
it's like i can't wait to call you and
be like
i'm worthless yeah when i have medical
nudes they go to jenna first yeah and
also like i had something really
traumatic happened to me the past few
months
and i remember telling jenna i was just
and she was she was like okay i don't
care whatever and i was like that's
exactly what i wanted you to say like
that's i just didn't want pity anyways
jenna's my best friend from college
she's an actress she because of me knows
kalila so now they're kind of like what
are you you guys are kind of the best
besties
i think you guys are family you guys are
like cousins yeah now for sure she's my
i would say like scissors
emotional support animal yeah it's
beyond friendship i think like i
when i travel
she's always there
next to my sister it's a corner are you
coming no i can't because it work go
straight to yeah if jenna can't come i'm
not going anywhere
like well guess that trip's out of there
yeah
yeah so we met in college and
we've just been in love ever since
more like trapped
but
it's stockholm syndromey with for all of
us i think also worth noting jenna is a
mexico
captain jenna jumenez the instagram
handle that you came up with which i
swear i remember hearing your last name
and being like she's jewish her her name
was jenna jewmen i bet it was because i
don't have a memory yeah coming up with
that yeah on my own and i remember that
i in
starting in seventh grade was called
jenna monster because my
friend's brother always called me jenna
monster but i was just like you're a
monster yeah that fits you yeah now i
when i was super little had a had a was
a family friend with a mexican jews and
then they moved away so then when i met
you i was like oh my god another mexican
jew that's the only juice do you mean
horchata
wait i don't get it
you mean like the jewmax tamarindo
the best joke i've ever come up with
aguas fresca
this [ __ ] everyone is so happy right
now and we're just happy because i'm
looking at how kalila was like
i have never seen her like that i'm
uncomfortable i'm gonna tell the
honestly that was a daddiest joke i've
ever told in my life when i met jenna
her claim to fame which i only knew
about this because our other friend
kristen was just a stalker
but this is so crazy jenna was on a
reality this is your claim to fame
i never tell anyone about this and
esther runs through the streets
literally continuing
was on a [ __ ] reality show when she
was in high school
called endurance
which was originally an nbc in the
winter's discovery kids it was a kids
yeah it was like survivor for kids and
listen to this
she was on that show she got voted back
as like the audience favorite to come
back for season two so she did two
seasons and she [ __ ] won season two
she won a reality show in high school
how weird is the only thing i've ever
won were you popular in high school
because of it i was popular in high
school i think that only popular girls
have that much confidence that they're
not popular because for unpopular girls
in my head i want to believe there were
moments of popularity like yeah i was
sort of like medium
i was very popular but it's more than
that i was very confident so like even
if i was unpopular i didn't it didn't
register
because
i did it in my second year of high
school and i remember i didn't tell
anyone
where i was what i was doing it was over
the summer
because i don't know i guess i just
thought it was loser or something like
the show i thought was loser but the
experience i thought was dope yeah the
people i met the things that we look at
her face of disgust just thinking of
like being on an island no i'm like this
is so cool you never talk about it so i
didn't tell anyone i'm also thinking
about how
the show had subtitles for you don't
even okay we're gonna get to that
so
okay you were
just wait brown
basically here's a blurb i'd like to
read for our audience from jenna
jimenez's endurance page
i like to be playful and i like to have
a good time and other people they tend
to be too serious
jenna
in her introduction in right to stay
this
is horrific
oh
my god he looks so cute though
dog collar on
yes
not like a cool kinky dog collar but one
from petco and then that jacket that i
was wearing was my father's from the 70s
like super small
short
your mom was so good at saving things
i'm so jealous oh real good at saving
things a little too good a little too
good there's a childhood my whole museum
there's my whole childhood is like a
museum at our house i need to visit it
and make sure you really should are
there things for sale oh and then the
subtitles what are they subtitle
i spoke very differently as a kid and
teenager because was it with a black
chicago
i want to say that it was unfortunately
a black set
mixed with maybe a little
like
latin slang the way my brother spoke
because my brother still speaks like
that but he doesn't hear it
which makes sense like i grew up in a
household with my mom speaking like my
yeah hello and then my brother being
like nah man like it's not like that you
know and then my dad like
you come over here you get the burger
king i'm like a hamburger so it's like
nothing at home made sense so when all
my friends at school spoke a certain way
and i spent most of my time with them
speak like your peer right no i totally
get that and i think that i did
a really terrible job trying to mimic
different um people from my high school
when i first came here my final phase
was talking like a weight girl
and that did not that was the worst part
was because there was no white people in
my school but i tried to like make
myself
yeah the club team that i went to like
all kids from like san marino la
crescent so i would try to mimic them it
was really really really a tragic time
for me in high school because you you
you seem
sick for having to like
go through six different accents trying
to like find who you are kalila can you
please read that i don't i can't read it
jenna is into hip-hop drama irish
dancing and swimming she has a wall in
her bedroom covered with graffiti
because she believes that anyone who
enters her room should speak their mind
freely and write down their thoughts
that was another thing i couldn't
believe she really had that and i still
like that i grew up like you cannot if
you're if there is a fingerprint on
these white walls you are in so much
[ __ ] trouble get your hand off the
wall get your did you touch the mirror
and then i walk into her house and
there's just drawing ever like i
couldn't believe it there was like a
dick on the wall
tits like that i'm coming down it's an f
word of course
um everywhere because at the age of like
nine i was like mom
i feel that everyone who enters my room
should be able to speak their mind and
she was like yeah they can speak their
mind and i was like
but they should feel like they can
really speak their mind so i'm gonna
start letting people speak their mind
onto my walls and i imagine in her head
she was like lord [ __ ] me in the ass
with no condom but out loud what came
out and she was like
okay
if that's what you feel
and then she just let it be wow my
your mom to be fair is one of the nicest
ladies my mom would have chopped off my
entire
forearms before i could even pick up
just your forearms and then attach your
hand to your elbows he's like try try
swimming now [ __ ] like
i was really lucky with my mom yeah but
remember your mom's reaction to your
tattoos your piercings yes so this is
like what was asked backwards everything
was like do whatever you want you should
be having sex you should be orgasming
blah blah blah in your mind
kind of trauma i think yeah it is i mean
that's why i didn't have sex when i was
19 because i was like no never no never
because you're associating it now with
something that your mom is into yeah and
i'm like that's not cool yeah
yeah i'm like i'm never doing that loser
[ __ ] yeah it's like the more you want
your kid to do it the more you forbid
them that's what she was like you should
have a mirror and you should be knowing
what your vagina looks like
i'm like
what
um is something preventing either of you
guys from achieving your goals or
interfering with your happiness yeah all
day every day like truly same truly
you need to check out betterhelp.com
trash tuesday listen you guys we all use
better help in fact
to be in our friend group it's a
requirement at this point oh yeah don't
call me if you haven't already used
betterhelp because i don't want to hear
it quite frankly correct there are
professionals who can actually help you
with your real lifestyle and they can
help you better with better health yes
it's an unbiased person able to give you
professional advice and you connect in a
safe and private online environment it's
so convenient and you can start
communicating with someone in under 48
hours trust me when i say this everyone
needs therapy everyone needs help no one
is no one is immune to this we all need
help and better help is such a way that
has made it so much more convenient for
me to communicate with a therapist
online i'm not sitting in a waiting room
i'm not dealing with parking or traffic
like it's all there safe from home it's
so damn convenient and i love that i can
send a message to my counselor anytime i
want to whether it's depression stress
anxiety family conflicts grief
self-esteem they have licensed
professional counselors who are
specialized in this anything you share
is confidential it's convenient
professional and affordable
um it's not it's not a crisis line
that's what our friend group calls jenna
for yeah
that's something else we want you to
start living a happier life today as a
listener you'll get 10 off your first
month by visiting our sponsor at
betterhelp.com
trash tuesday join over 1 million people
who have taken charge of their mental
health again that's
betterhelphelp.com trash tuesday all
right you guys
there's a new
water brand at the stores you know
you've seen it you've seen it at whole
foods you've seen it at 7 11 you've seen
it on my freaking tick tock and on
jenna's chest and literally spilled all
over i just sent my parents a case of it
and they're like oh we're gonna serve it
to the neighbors when they come over
tonight i'm like they're my parents are
gonna be so bad ass the coolest people
in skokie liquid
death
liquid
is the like i just don't know why it
makes me happy it also tastes very good
i crack open a can i feel like i'm so
cool i feel like i'm riding high but the
secret is it's literally water i'm
literally opening a can of water i'm not
that cool but i get to feel cool and
their sparkling water is so sparkly it
like attacks my face it's so it's like
gives me all the tingles that i'm
looking for
and why is it called liquid death ester
because death to plastic [ __ ] okay
we have aluminum cans so you don't have
to worry about it sitting and rotting
and it's plastic you don't feel guilty
like you're bad for the environment dude
this is the way to just have it grab and
go i put a case of them in my trunk in
the trunk of my car so i i'm always know
that okay there's a case of water in
there i'm good and it's not like plastic
where it'll melt and get disgusting i
also feel like this is your dream come
true because you've always wanted to
remain sober while looking like a drunk
person that's right and as you hear any
story i told them this episode you'll
hear why it was very traumatizing when a
guy ditched me
because i was sober this could have
solved that problem you guys can get
free shipping on all water and merch at
liquiddeth.com
trash that's liquiddeth.com
trash and that's a huge deal because
honestly it's not cheap to ship this
it's really heavy and they're covering
the cost it's literally free
shipping at liquiddeath.com trash or go
grab some at whole foods or 7-eleven you
know you know you see it you know you
want to be cool
wait what do you have and donut is like
definitely thinking
oh what's in the box
what's in the [ __ ] box
so jenna's gonna have the box on her lap
and uh put her hand in the box and say
guess what's in there does donut get a
try
has a hole in it
[Applause]
[Music]
this is literally an attack on me
because you guys know i have a story
about this food that made me cry in
vegas it's pulpo
it's octopus leg i know it should make
me cry because i don't eat octopus
because they're sentient beings
oh was this so that other people could
see got it i wanted to avoid hitting
microphones so weird the way that this
show it's like every week they present
me with something i'm scared of the
audience hates me more i think that's an
attack for me i think when you're scared
of everything it's kind of hard not to
present anything that's uh it's true
double cheeseburger i will not be scared
oops
thank you p thank you
um oh my god this is
camaron
oh
whoa
one-handed [ __ ] you good
thank you i feel like it feels the same
if i like put my [ __ ] in there and you
were just like
on camaron
if you honestly put one of your [ __ ]
in the box they would have had the same
answer
i'm not feeling well today what's new i
have a doctor's note what's new
i have the delta variant
you are the delta variant
your patient's zero
no why are you laughing
why are you laughing
i don't know it looks funny to me why
isn't it funny why is it funny
is it funny you just stick your hand in
[ __ ] and you'll figure out because i
don't want to touch a prawn like it's
not a problem
for someone who is very willing to fist
my [ __ ] you should be very good at
this game like you're such a dirty [ __ ]
you should be able to touch it
it's nothing worse than any amount of
time that you haven't showered no that
is so
it's just like i
like i just talked to it i like left my
parents house to move to l.a
if you want to tell your story about how
you met me or whatever no don't touch it
it's just like why did i come here to do
stand up comedy and now i'm like having
people egg me on to put my hand in a box
but i don't know what's in it it's just
like stand-up comedy is the hardest
thing anybody can do and you won't put
your hand in a box
[Laughter]
[Music]
your hand esther it's fine
look where she's putting her hand she's
gonna be like air there's nothing
now that's weird mine must have jumped
out just smash it smash it in there yeah
it's not alive right be brave little i
mean esther look at me it's fine make a
wish wait for each sound my little tear
no you're not gonna be mad you're gonna
be like oh i'm a dumb [ __ ]
it's not alive right
it's a it's it's a living thing
it's not alive though it's a living
organism
what do you mean esther you gotta think
about what a living organ what's a
living thing what what makes a living
thing
eyes
[Applause]
eyeball
okay i'm gonna do what the tsa does like
around my special parts i'm gonna go
back on my hand this is how they deal
with special parts of the tsa they do
the back of the hand to my breast yeah
it's very impersonal get very like okay
smash it down some more is it really
from sugar fish
it feels is there sugar fish here it
feels like sushi
what's your final answer esther
turn your hand downward
your palms are where your nerves are at
how are you going to identify an object
when your nerves have not touch it yeah
what would a nurse do esther a nurse
would get in the car and drive straight
to the hospital and help out get to know
what an actual hemorrhoid feels like
i really do not like what you think
about your nurse you're putting a
suppository you i don't you're making
doughnut nervous it feels like it has
skin ester you're making
doughnut nerves it hasn't it definitely
has skin it definitely has it definitely
has a skin mm-hmm it definitely has skin
1000 percent has skin
kylie you got so much joy
that's just the way she's tapping it
she said it definitely okay i totally
touched
to just put it yeah put it in your hand
why would i do because you're a nurse
nurse asked her what would nurse esther
do
[Laughter]
oh my god i squeezed it and i thought it
was gonna like you know just my fingers
i don't know what it is you may have
guessed you want a bouncy ball
[Music]
it's a sushi
sushi is she me is it
[Music]
yeah i told you i told you
i thought i gave it away with
hemorrhoids
i gave you my eyes and my trust and you
didn't take it yeah but that could have
been meant like yeah it's a scary thing
but you'll live
no i said esther that's so unfair i gave
you a layup asking if it has skin
it's a living thing plants animals are
living oh my god oh my god i haven't
just been humiliated the fact that she
said
eyes
sorry all right jenna is up next clown
don't look at it like that oh what
you're a whole lot of my feet
no no
jenna you would love no no no i know for
a fact that jenna listen all i'm saying
is i don't [ __ ] around no no no no no
jenna you'd like this you just gotta go
just don't kill it
so gentle yeah no this is actually
unacceptable like i will walk if it's a
cockroach no no no i would never do that
to you i wouldn't be in this room if it
was a [ __ ] cockroach george if you
bought a [ __ ] cockroach for me a worm
yes jenna loves earthworms
you like it i like it she loves them how
did you get those
[Laughter]
i know that if you had accidentally
killed one it would have ruined your
whole day my heart is still racing from
the plums
i am like i should i need a break
i need a break what kind of banana or a
plum break
we did a banana break this early that's
the earliest banana bread this is like
not what i signed up for
i am really just i need to i need to lie
down oh you're winded yeah yeah i can
tell you're like lightheaded i don't
feel well all right is it my turn oh no
we'll do it we're doing esther again oh
okay yeah just go straight for it be
fast you know why
you can deduce what it is if you ask me
three good questions is it alive no no
was it ever alive
yeah possibly from a living thing yes
esther look at me in my eyes this is
this is the second time i'm gonna do it
it's okay
what's your third what's your third
question would have would a vegan eat it
no okay that makes things different
because a vegan would eat the last one
and if i knew that i would go in with my
mouth
you would go in with your mouth but this
is something that a vegan wouldn't eat
but it was maybe alive before
i mean sourced from living things yes
sore source
so is it honey esther three questions
earth means three questions oh she is
mean
just dig your hand and you're gonna be
fine really run yes so you're touching
the plate no i'm not you are she's doing
this to the plate
and her eyes were like it feels almost
like mochi stick a nail into it yeah
stick a nail into it
that's mean the way you say it with a
big smile
like you're just so
happy oh donut likes it it feels like a
mochi it feels like a dessert classic a
classic go for classics a ho ho that's
the name of our show it's definitely
like it's definitely like squishy
and look if it's a sea creature i'm
going to be upset if it's not i'm okay
it is very similar to a sea creature
similar
i don't i think it's a mochi dessert
okay good guess final answer good guess
that is a twink twinkie
are you serious you know what this is
crazy wow you're a dumb [ __ ] yeah
yeah and if i had put my wow
do you guys know that when i went when
my great-grandma was still alive we had
to leave twinkies on the counter for her
to eat in the middle of the night what
it's cause her sugar would dry i don't
know i think it's because she got hungry
and she didn't have her teeth in
uh it is an easy um gum i can't believe
it was a twinkie i and i got and you
guys got me twice in a row
you got yourself your line of
questioning is was almost perfect yeah
here's the thing it's like
i would expect that if it was a scary
thing like octopus then i would be like
really like that
but because i didn't know what it is i
still feel that crazy fear that like
i still feel like [ __ ] body and fight or
flight yes it is
it is important show me your armpits are
you sweating no i'm not i'm not like you
nothing has happened jenna put your hand
under my armpits now nothing has
happened right
nothing has happened to me but please
just touch
what what
esther you want to put your fingers in
my armpit it's like i just shove it yeah
i do that i'll do here you want to try
my right arm but just get in there fully
it looks like
vagina discharge so
wet
it's so
wet i feel like mine is really wet right
now too like underneath now you're not
as wet as you
yeah you're like dripping wet sopping
wet stopping yeah also my hands and feet
that's my favorite thing about her
when your feet drip i'm like when i my
feet are dripping i send pictures to
you a healthier person because like
sweating is good for you it makes my
hands and feet look really young
so yes should i have an only fans of
just my young feet yes i want to start
an only fans or something with my feet
because the amount of people i get
asking me here's what i think you should
do my feet i think you should irish
dance on top of some cake we we do like
a a focus right on your feet
that'll
i have my heart shoes still and my dress
well let's take the shoes off because i
don't think you'll get a lot of bucks
for that
yeah but you do have very pretty feet i
think that my hands
stay very um soft in between the sweat
sessions because of the sweat but
yeah like people do not believe how what
an anxious fight or flighty person i am
until
they get close but you're not anxious in
fight or flight now i am i always am yes
she is the cameras are on i'm always
dying i'm always
dying on the inside
but i've made it in my life's mission to
not show
make it obvious to someone are you just
learning this i guess
i i always thought that your sweatiness
hadn't i didn't think that it had
something to do with how you actually
felt i thought it was just like some
people sweat more she's always on the
verge of a panic attack
pastor one time i called jenna from
mcgelson's produce aisle and i called
her crying and i was like i have this
fear that i'm going to forget who i am
like i thought i
was she goes and i don't remember anyone
else's name but yours and i was like and
she had to pick me up and i was frozen
she dropped
those eyes i dropped everything i had in
my cart and i was she picked me up and i
was like a
statue just wheeled her out it's so
weird because you i feel like you know
like the low kalai la low status kalila
and i only know high status yeah like to
me kalila is like
such a boss [ __ ] like but that's part
of the bitchness because it's like
imagine feeling like that and still
doing stuff yeah yeah
literally you want to talk about fear
i'm afraid of breathing
at night i call jenna in a panic like i
don't know why i keep holding my breath
for no reason like if someone says relax
breathe focus on your breath it throws
me into a bigger panic oh that's true i
told you the other day
yeah i used to be like that with jenna
too
until i started my alexa pro
shout out alexa bro
it was just a mere year ago that
i was a nightmare that you were still a
nightmare i might be joining you soon i
might be hopping back these pictures
have changed i tell people how much how
different you are i don't like to say
better because it's like
no yeah you're better
but like
you were just
i don't want to say unbearable either
well like
obviously i was
very very close with you and i loved you
still the same because in my mind i'm
like oh that's just esther there's no
yeah there's no other esther
but now that i see you
i'm like she's alive yeah i was just so
i my anxiety like ruled everything right
and i didn't know that it was like
really your anxiety but when i looked
because that's all i knew but when i
look back and i'm like oh you were
constantly scared what were you most
scared of what is the one thing you feel
like you fixated on well i was sort of
thinking keep in mind like i was a
hypochondriac in which you know
i text both of you about like
ailments i think the amount of time she
had me come over and like check on
things or smell things in her house
or like get a second opinion just for me
and now it's like you live
my like old life you're like
trees
like this is
how my life was before remember when you
used to be like how do you just do that
how can you just pick up and go on a
trip like yeah i mean have you been on a
trip since you started lexapro outside
of the country uh not outside oh well i
went to montreal but that was for work
do i get three questions what is that
but i don't know what i am a super
smeller i should just
i don't know what it is to you
oh
it's it smells like a food of sorts it
looks it looks like a food
well i know for sure it's not a living
thing because i smell like a stale food
so
can you twist it toward me and show me
yeah i think it's something that's i
think it's something that i know
yes it is
will you mouth it to me it actually
feels like a sea cucumber
oh look at her face
i'm gonna go ahead
hold on it's either it it's it could be
a cow tongue
oh if that's a if no is flatter than
this
it it is
wait oh hold on it has roots
she's pulling a string out of it it's
not a string it's attached to it it's
one of a fiber i i don't think it's a
sea cucumber because it i think it's a
wet vegetable of sorts
it smells like that but i'm that's i
can't think of another uh vegetable so
i'm just going to go ahead and say sea
cucumber what does it mean wait wait
isn't it
or whatever it's going yeah
you're right isn't that what it is
because i remember growing up my mom
used to be like [ __ ] the monkey god damn
it because she would go to the um
can i just say because you when i was
scared you guys were like if you are a
nurse you would do it a nurse knows what
they're touching when they have their
eyes are open first off i didn't say
that but i just want to say so you would
never be a nurse to be a nurse
should we give esther one more to prove
her nurse them no no no no no no no
we're done we're done we're done with
this game
why did we stop eating cereal as adults
dude because it's bad for you and it's
like full of sugar it was the happiest
though i know
dude that is why magic spoon is my
favorite thing ever to be invented it's
so delicious and i can just shove a bowl
down and not feel bad at all because
it's filled protein and it's like it's
it's good for you zero grams of sugar 13
to 14 grams of protein and only four net
grams of carbs in each serving only 140
calories a serving it's keto friendly
gluten free grain free soy free low carb
and gmo free oh my god i forgot they
sent i just got the new the two new
flavors they brought back the cookies
and cream and the maple waffle syrup
it's so
good it's so breakfasty and like sweet
and indulgent but there's no guilt about
it i want you need it yeah you need it
come over here i'll give you a bubble we
have it yeah i want it now
so flavors include cocoa
fruity frosted peanut butter blueberry
cinnamon and what esther mentioned
cookies and cream and maple waffle
subscribe today to flavors you love and
you can get cereal shipped to your
doorstep not to mention saving more than
25 on every order you can choose four
flavors you love edit your subscription
switch it up and keep yourself stocked
up on cereal go to magicspoon.com
tuesday5 or use our promo code tuesday5
at checkout to get five dollars off your
order and try it today remember if you
subscribe to magic spoon you get five
dollars off on top of the 25 savings
from subscribing and magic spoon is so
confident in their product it's backed
with a 100 happiness guarantee so if you
don't like it for any reason they'll
refund your money no questions asked
remember subscribe and get your
delicious guilt-free cereal on the
regular at magicspoon.com
tuesday5 and use the code tuesday5 to
save big thank you so much magicspoon
for sponsoring this episode we love you
thank you i'm having you for dinner
tonight it's really hard to navigate
skincare products and to know when
there's so many options out there which
one is right for you what ingredients
are best for you and you know are you
going to spend all this money on like
random marketing is it going to work
yeah dude that is why apostrophe is such
a game changer because it is a
prescription skin care company that
offers science-backed oral and topical
medications that are clinically proven
to help clear acne an apostrophe will
connect you with a board-certified
dermatologist who will create a
personalized treatment plan that is
perfectly tailored to your skin all you
have to do simply fill out apostrophe's
online quiz about your skin goals and
medical history then snap a few selfies
and your dermatologist will create your
customized treatment plan an apostrophe
treats acne and they can also help you
hit your other skin care goals like
reducing redness which is absolutely
mine i'm so red wrinkles and even dark
spots
for me there are several things wrong
with my skin number one i suffer from
eczema i have melasma in my upper lip
dark spots
acne hormonal acne all of the above
apostrophe has changed my life the fact
that you have a dermatologist at your
fingertips is a life changer well
there's just real thing real solutions
out there that only a doctor can really
help you with and like i know for me
when my skin was bad compared to the
confidence i feel since i have kind of
gotten my skin in place with a doctor's
help like it really can just be a
confidence booster which can make your
whole life better you look good you feel
good you act good and people don't know
this but the skin fun fact is the
largest organ in our body
we should be taking care of it you guys
we have a special deal for our audience
save 15 off your first visit with a
board-certified dermatologist at
apostrophe.com
tuesday when you use our code tuesday
this code is only available to our
listeners so to get started just go to
apostrophe.com
tuesday and click begin visit then use
our code tuesday at sign up and you'll
get 15 off your dermatology visit that's
a-p-o-s-t-r-o-p-h-e
dot com slash tuesday and use that code
tuesday to get your dermatology visit
and save 15 and we thank apostrophe for
sponsoring this podcast
it's so weird that like all three of us
it's like a weird triangle like we have
a really close relationship separate you
guys have a really close relationship
and then we're like i don't know what we
are but i'm in love with you i'm in love
with you
but like it's we we've never all
no
minds it's interesting that kalila's
turned very mean when we're all together
[Laughter]
but this is so much fun like it is fun
because i know this is
it's f it's like it's almost like i can
feel close with kalila that we both know
so much about you i know
i feel like you too
like there might not be anyone else
aside from sosie and you know stuff from
like even before i moved here yeah but
it's weird that people you love i love
hmm it's it i don't know if there's
they're all so different they are also
different but here
but i love them all like i
adore so yeah i really like sosi too so
it's like they haven't really met anyone
through you and again you
you gave me one of the biggest
contributions in my life because she
gave me one of the contributions of my
life which is shandy
one of my other really really close
girlfriends i met through her oh i don't
know her well i'm chicago too chicago
yeah i love that's like one of my
warm spots like sharing my friends
it's always my goal to like
push them on each other or like when i
left chicago i would give
friends there who i knew would get along
super close friends each other's numbers
and be like hey well i'm not there how
about when i left and then you took over
my babysitting job and now like we both
have such a good relationship with that
family oh my god like that's so special
to me i feel like you left a trail for
me that i just followed you go do this
go do this wait also klyla i want to
tell you this because i feel like you'll
really understand you'll be like the one
person that gets it the moment that i
knew i was full okay donut is eating
your brain through your nose um the
moment that i knew jenna was like so
special and i need to be your friend
forever is very strange but like
we were we used to we took this class
fish in 101 food science and healthy
what's it called fishing
hn
food science oh
it was like a big lecture hall at
university of illinois like just you
know huge whatever and for some reason
every class me and jenna and our third
friend kristen would sit in the front
row our third friendly that's the only
one we had our third friend and like so
we would always sit in the front row and
like keep in mind like the first ten
rows are empty nobody is like everyone
is way back
and
so we'd always everyone's like asleep
and hide yeah
and we were so into this class and
one day jenna had like brought a snack
with her and i was like oh my god like
that looks so good can i have some and
she's like
i can't even
this is what she says to me i can't even
believe you would dare ask me knowing
what a busy day i have that you would
dare ask me for a bite of my food i
can't believe that i ever said that
because i'm so generous but i also know
that esther was probably always pushing
it and i knew that she would be like
i'll finish it no i'll just eat it but
then i was like oh my god like something
just came over me where i was like
she just like so aggressively told me
that she's not sharing with me
i'm like i'm like i'm in like i love
this
you love the vibe of the kid who offers
the chips but crunches the bottom seed
you can't get that much you can only
really get like one or two chips
that's the vibe she gave off it was just
like oh i want to be like that too i
want to tell people [ __ ] no you can't
have a fry because the thing is is that
that's how you really felt all the time
yeah no you cannot have a fry but would
die being like okay yeah
but i would also say like i was sharing
all the time yeah you are a sharer now
but it that was a very awesome but if
it's like this is what i packed and i
have six hours at the library right now
and eleven dollars in my bank account
you are not good yeah she was counting
her macros on a budget that's
that's also i feel like an experience
that we had in college is sort of like
why i felt like i had to make my
stand-up special the way that i made it
was because i have it's like stand-up
intercut with like scenes with my
parents oh this is and that is kind of
because of the first time you met my
parents what you said to me i was like
it i don't know will you tell kalyala
yeah so basically
i had never met esther's parents but we
were in
college right we were in college which
the way we met is like this whole other
story but
we're in college and
esther probably convinced me to drive
her home this weekend and
i'm going to her childhood home i'm
meeting her parents i'm like this is
going to be so cool
we're in her house
and immediately i'm like
something is not right
like
well i can't put my finger on it but
what's wrong with this household and not
like they were mean or rude but it was
just like so
peculiar
in a way that i was like
okay let me just like keep observing and
try and figure out like how i fit in
here and then we get into the van right
there's a van and we head to somewhere
in evanston yeah to go eat her mom and
dad are just going back and forth and
talking about like what they're gonna
order for dinner or something and like
asking esther but also being kind of
aggressive about it
and i was i remember having this moment
and like looking out the window and
being like
i get it
i get her entire existence are the way
you are and why it makes no sense
because they make no sense but are all
like
how someone can be so particular
but also there's like
no sense behind it yeah that is weird
about you because i feel like there are
certain things that you're very
particular like she said particular
about but you also live with a lot more
abandon yeah um than alexa pro
no but even before that um yeah so it's
sort of it's a weird mix it's you're
very similar to bobby in that way yeah i
i think that i'm bobby i think you are
i'm not as talented but i [ __ ]
identify with him
imagine if that's something in the
future it's just something that you can
do it's just i identify as bobby as
bobby
and then like no one can take that away
yeah i am bobby lee like for sure
i think so he is his own because he's
his own species yeah yeah i think he's
there he always says there are
12 human prototypes he's one and you
know we all on we fall under each one of
those 12 prototypes you fall under the
the
yeah yeah
made in the 1940s
oh yeah um not the most efficient from
modern day but beloved
and held in high regard as a vintage
piece
disgusting and dirty
hygiene questionable
needs refurbishing for sure
you know what's crazy though too is that
i never really thought you were
odd
until
i met your parents because then i saw it
on someone else and i was like
oh it all makes sense
like i don't remember
why are you confused i'm just listening
thinking that you were like weird
because you were you're
weird well i was weird i don't feel like
i'm weird anymore well you can just be
not weird anymore just because you like
live in l.a and everyone's yeah like i
still think you're like dry shave in
public places yeah but that's like not
that's just like an example that's not
the actual weirdness that it's like the
weirdness is underneath that that's just
like a behavior of how it manifests got
it got it you're still so weird
right
oh yeah
what oh yeah i i but i i think that's
i'm not offended i'm just like that's
not how i would assess myself
not to say that i have a criteria for
friends but
the weirder the better for me i'm a
voyeur i like watching weird people do
that yeah i have that too and i love it
it's actually really [ __ ] up
it's a [ __ ] up quality because i i
feel like my friend like my sane friends
are always like you just need to like
start watching tv shows so you can stop
hanging out with the insane people
like just watch it on a show like yeah
you absorb it that way
yeah not you're not that like you're
just weird in like a fun way not in the
like
yeah you're you're the weirdest
you're the weirdest sober person i know
like i've never seen someone look so
high at
at a club
i've never seen someone look so high on
pcp
while not being on pcp you know what i
mean yeah people
yeah i don't know what to say i'm like
oh she's making out with an inanimate
object but she's sober i promise you
guys she's over people were always like
no i i've seen you drunk and i'm like
people i've been friends with for like
20 years
oh my wait should we banana break yeah
do i get a banana yeah yeah
do you you weren't with me but it was at
that frat party the remember the one
frat house that i would go to all the
time that we have a picture at yeah was
all the ugly guys
also in college every guy like jenna
love
they still do uh and i was just acting
like how we act you know like just being
really silly crazy running around like
dancing like obnoxious doing weird [ __ ]
and this whole night this one guy was
talking to me the whole night
and then one of my girlfriends who like
lived in my building with me was there
too and she goes she's laughing she's
like esther
this is what i love about you you act
like this and you are dead sober and the
guy who i've been flirting with all
night like having so much fun with you
just looks and he's like you're sober
i'm like yeah and he literally walked
out of the room and didn't talk to me
the rest of the night it was so
traumatized because he
was he had been so [ __ ] up that he was
like oh [ __ ] no or was he like gonna
rape me like yeah it's like i have no
interest in this person i cannot take
advantage of that because she has a
clearer mind than me in this moment no i
thought she was gonna
how [ __ ] up is that no you remember no
guys liked me in college i liked you
that was all i needed
didn't know guys like him oh this is sad
i didn't feel like that
that's sad that's like when the mom is
like oh i think guys like
[Applause]
oh there was the one oh no not him
the one time at the oh that was lena
well we all
our friend group definitely loves
bringing this name up but i don't know
if you know it
do i remember then you don't because
was he the frat boy there was one frat
guy that i kind of had a thing with
oh that was his name yeah
but then one time he was his mom sent
him puppy chow you know that like it's
like
that like snack that like moms make wait
electric comics um yeah it's like a it's
like for people but it's called puppy
chow and it's like uh i don't know
marshmallows and chex mix and chocolate
powder powdered sugar
and when we were sitting on his bed and
like we he was like sharing with me and
then he was like i think you had too
much of it and he like took it away from
me
did you fart or something what did you
fart no i think he just like wanted to
keep it for himself
and i was eating too much
that would be really funny if it was
real puppy challenge and
jacob jacob that's so cute
one of the most humiliating times i've
ever hooked up with a guy at unlv he
played baseball
um
the night after thankfully we never had
sex but you know we had a whole lot of
um smoochin
um and granted we were both like pretty
drunk
but the amount of times he asked me what
my name was that the morning after
really broke my heart and i know i have
a difficult name to remember
but he was like wait what's your name
again malaysia
and i'm like oh close enough
thank you so much for remember
remembering
he had like 18 different variations of
my name and i remember as soon as he
left the door like i cried really
yeah why what did you feel
i just felt um
like that was the least he could have
done
is commit my
my name to to memory yeah because then
it just felt like wow he really
does not remember what we did is not
interested me in any way he just wanted
like a blind blackout hookup
and that's what i was like and then the
fact that he kept asking your name it's
like if you don't remember it just just
drop it ask just let yeah just drop it
yeah and then my friend was like maybe
he has a learning disability i was like
i'll take that
that's what i'll move forward he's
stupid that's right
remember your boobs were bigger and
colder they were huge and actually just
a couple weeks ago they were huge
because i was bleeding but i had a 34
double d like my breasts came up to my
collarbone yeah it was crazy
yeah it was crazy you remember you had
huge tits that was really fun they were
huge esther would constantly just walk
up to me and pull my shirt down and like
touch them or look at them no listener
on this show is surprised to hear that
estherista moves
um i said the most esteristic moves
all right do we want to do the lie
detector you can't handle the truth
in regards to lie detectors i think i
could be the most innocent person on
earth and fail every single day
based on my armpits yeah for sure and my
heart rate always being high i totally
think that you're right like i would
have to knock myself out with fentanyl
before i would pass any lie detector so
okay go ahead
i've all you know what's interesting on
the reverse of that i've always felt
like oh a lie detector that must be so
easy to
like to fake and now that it's here i
literally my heart is pounding like the
fact that we're talking about it
oh my gosh it's a kid's toy
it's already short-circuited because my
palms are sopping wet so you guys can
either ask your own questions we have
some sample questions if you want to go
off our list or choose your own are you
attracted to bobby yes how do we find
out
[ __ ] wet just
i love little mustache asian man yeah
she's so attracted to him but to be
still attracted is weird
that's a good point
esther loses attraction after like 14
hours yeah are you attracted to me
no
that's not a real question that was just
a joke one
well you get to your [ __ ] fault no
all right
ready
this is like sharp like a shark um are
you allergic to gluten
no
are you sensitive to gluten yes ow
what did you do wait did you lie
i said no i'm not allergic to it but i
am sensitive to it but you might i
[ __ ] it up i [ __ ] it up i [ __ ] it
up wrong
obviously okay next question okay
okay this one's a yeah i'm gonna pull
one of these scary yeah
okay quick i'm scared have you ever um
not changed your underwear underwear for
longer than two days no
i hope it says you're lying
why does he keep doing this
is it my rings
it's shocking me i'm a liar jenna now do
you know how afraid i am jenna is there
everywhere i know that that's a [ __ ]
up thing because jenna is
probably she probably scrubs it with a
brillo pad that's how paranoid she is
can we ask can we ask again i'm going to
take my ring off
the question which confused me i would
not have known how to answer it i'm
afraid of this thing do you like bobby
for me
yes
i'm telling the truth i don't know what
to say i'm chilling like me
but like pass it to us there no wait can
we see if this is ever going to say no
i'm done with that that's actually a
good question because i'm i've like
never thought of you with anyone but
yeah and when people ask me about you
with bobby i'm like there's no one else
and i do believe you there's no one else
for the record
hi little baby
are you obsessed with dodie
yes
i'm so scared right now it's going to
shock me
yeah let's get it off
that is like a taser it is so severe or
i'm just in a room full of liars
it's like obviously you're obsessed with
your dog that thing is false
oh it broke my you know how many times i
just felt that
it's like an electric it's really bad
that feels like when i got electrocuted
in argentina this is not once let me
tell you a story let me tell you
something about electrocution you guys i
grew up in a country where the wiring is
faulty everywhere every other day when i
turned on the [ __ ] bathroom lights it
was a shock to my entire system and i
think this is probably why i have heart
issues it's also probably why
i'm stacks i think that my brain is has
been rewired in some way because of all
that electrical charge as a youngin
do you think you have super powers um
yeah genuinely your brain is super
powers yeah but for basic things like
which way to push a door like push or
pull i can't figure it out oh yeah she's
like
i know you were gonna say that was your
super power always knowing the picture
isn't a super power i was like the
amount of times jenna has seen me just
run into a door or like basic things
panic because she's like
did i read that wrong i don't i tried to
pull but i oh yeah i short circuit for
the dumbest things but should we you
don't want any more questions i guess
i'll take one more but this thing is
fake what if i like start getting into
the shocks and then i need it to get off
that's like what my okay oh my god have
you ever worn underwear for longer than
four days
no
i have
i don't think i yeah okay
that's false
yo [ __ ] that she's happy i didn't get
shot you need to call fisher price and
be like that's a no when i was younger
though i you guys never did side a side
b
because you were not i was a nasty kid
right you're like oh [ __ ] it i'll just
flip my underwear oh i did that yeah
especially when i was spent the summer
in new york i maybe have done that once
i had laundry i mean you know i'm like
paranoid with vagina area pinworms like
um jenna last week had a pinworm um
emergency what
she thought she had worms and i'm sure
she did because she's you're the panties
knowing the she had little sensations in
her bum bum i had sensations in my butt
did you have worms so i took the
medicine
because i i it is my fear yeah to have
pinworms
what is pinworms there's just kids kids
get them kids get it it's worms in your
doodoo it's worms uh that go
in your intestines is it the ones that
make you skinny that's a tapeworm you
want to buy one in mexico can you really
do that
worms could make you skinny because they
feed off your glucose but like
you would need to have like a lot and be
reinfected and yeah tapeworms are gnarly
because you end up getting like sort of
this like beer gut you might be skinny
up here but you
have like a bloat to you
um i one time falsely diagnosed a
co-worker at abercrombie with tapeworm
because i didn't like her
and she was really mean to everyone
around her
and so
one time she was like i haven't i don't
i don't feel well and i was like i'm
pretty sure you have a pretty
t-shirt and i showed her a picture of
what someone with a tapeworm looks like
and she was like convinced she had a
tapeworm i was like where have you
traveled recently what kind of foods
have you eaten
she was such a [ __ ] what happened to
her
nothing she probably went to the doctor
and asked if she had a tapeworm she
would always make me like get the sizes
in the back where was this abercrombie
fitch yeah glendale galleria oh no i
hate mean girls [ __ ] [ __ ] oh no
yeah i don't like that machine yeah yeah
that machine is false yeah i can i can
you're very different go on the record
and say that jenna has the most pristine
vagina
in the world wait why are they saying
that that's not true oh because it was
like
she i i she keeps it washing yeah we
didn't say it looks nice did you wash it
do you wash it in the chicken doesn't
look nice unfortunately i do with what
dr bronner's or this one that's like ph
but you don't do you think you need to
wash your vagina with something i so
i've had a very in the last two years i
have completely stopped soaping
my vagina and i helped you it is no more
beasty yeasties feeling
so sprightly down there feeling very
clean less discharged less irritation
i washed the [ __ ] out of my [ __ ]
though
why do you wash it then
i don't know i'm just like always
paranoid about getting something i wash
it digitally like i mechanical water
[ __ ] with water
mechanically like i take out the the
you know the creams what
you don't know you know the creams no i
don't ester i'm not kidding what are you
talking about esther do you not remember
calling me like four years ago and being
like come with me to give her another
lie detector
does esther have the crease put the
thing back on her hand
okay okay okay
yeah
never mind
so do you have the creams i don't call
that that but i know i i just can't
guess what you think you're saying you
know what's funny it's magma at the
gynecologist's office yesterday
i blanked i've been blanking a lot
lately and i'm sitting there like this
and i was like i just had a question
about my
you know um
she's like your vagina and she's sitting
there with her gloves on with her
assistant my legs open and i'm like
uh my
hold on just give me a moment
you know the stuff that in your vagina
and she's like
what are you trying to say and i was
like just give me a moment
discharge and she's like oh
yeah what about it and apparently
so
i
we all have discharge yeah but i
haven't really had normal discharge like
i don't really have a lot
and i didn't know that it was because
most likely because of my pcos and so
i'm not ovulating and so when you're
ovulating is when you get thicker like
gushing ovulating is when you get the
egg white
it feels very wet down there yeah and
like milky and so
i've never really had that maybe every
now and then
but
so i was like i just have a question
about my discharge it's like
milk
something she's
she's like what do you mean i'm like
yeah it's just like you know kind of all
of a sudden i'm like whoa there's like
milk running down my leg or something
and she was like you're lying no really
this is yesterday you can call it
dripping yeah it's like all of a sudden
it like gushes and you're like oh gushes
yeah it's like all all of a sudden it'll
be like a
oh i know that but it's not milk it's
like
egg white it's sperm
it's a sperm but it's not it's not as
thick for me maybe
yeah that's what's throwing me off i'm
thinking of a thin milk yeah it's like a
milky like one percent it's like it's
like the top of the yogurt it's a skim
part yeah well that's not milk on the
top of the yogurt that's a clear
we should the go-go queen knows all
about i know is it gloopy gloppy like
movie and gloppy are the same they're
not
they're
not anyhow she was like i'll take a look
so
she goes in with the speculum yeah
speculum
the little duck mouth
worse
worst thing i used to ask for the small
one the small size
so she got that one
one time the small one got lost in you
what happened
why can't they my mom is calling
hey mom
yes
you called me
yeah what i was going to tell you is
like
what up why why are you calling
is that funny
wait just before you say anything you
are on a podcast right now with me
kleiland esther
is she microwaving something
okay what was your first impression of
esther
like did you think i don't remember i
think she met my mom before she met me
well she i know she did mom what are
your thoughts about kalila i love kalila
oh but she said that like i love kalila
yeah like not esther but i love delilah
my mom's obsessed with you
well remember when when
i asked your mom after she met your
boyfriend what'd she think of him and
she wouldn't
she's like like a script she would not
stray from she kept saying i've met him
before
i've met him before
translation is and you haven't done it
yet
i'm telling you every single month maybe
she'll reference something since i moved
here that's like well esther did this
you should have done this because astro
did it how parents
why did you get back to stand up pastor
did it do it 100 did you see it she'll
write to me she'll write to me
what is this and it's a screenshot of
something you've just posted on
instagram oh my god it's so annoying and
i'm like it's it's what it looks like
it's a picture
of esther
in front of a tree
well what what is she doing dude the
last time i was home my mom i was like
mom am i
did i gain weight and she's like well if
you have to ask
it's like our mom is just like
you're never gonna be good
set your mom free
okay mom love you we're gonna go thank
you jerry bye
bye
that is true about you esther what
say what you will about sweet little
esther but you have a fortitude and a
persistence that is unmatched and i have
so much respect for you it's insane
thank you yeah you want it you get it
it's like you have to be insane to do
that jenna um you guys i'm gonna plug it
on her behalf because she sucks at
self-promotion i'm not great at
self-promotion either but she's worse
than me oh um the people
everyone knows i have the sweatiest
armpits um in los angeles
and one of the things that i am never
despite having the sweaty is our bits is
smelly that's true you can attest to
this he smelled my armpits and that is
because jenna has the best concoction of
homemade deodorant so everybody go to um
is it my tiagena it's oh which is also a
name that esther came up with it's
called pit stop
by tia jenna
and so the brand is by tia jenna so
where do you go to get it
go to my instagram and then which is
jenna jumenez and then in the profile it
says buy tia jenna and you just click on
it and follow or you can just go to
i think buy tea it's in my instagram
there is no kaleila you go back to the
promotions yeah you should can you shut
the [ __ ] up shut the [ __ ] up no but
honestly this is i it's so crazy that
this is something that you make because
literally i
would not be able to show up at work
without this it's so it's weird it works
that's all it's like you [ __ ] took
your crazy wacko genius brain and you
made something really good and i'm like
obsessed you know it sucks can i have
some ideas yeah there can be there can
be no better test subject
than me
you'd be hard pressed to find a better
test subject faster for smell
of esther um and you did a [ __ ]
genius job so everybody go get pit stop
i would be like me and esther you know
what sucks is that i didn't sosie always
says she emotionally connects with the
smell i do too yeah in fact when she
feels anxious sometimes she just goes
yeah it's a very
grounding smell
my armpits look if you need a good whiff
of relaxation just smell my armpits and
i started making it like six years ago
but because i'm very bad at business
well i was like talking there so go to
she's not bad at business pit stop tia
jenna
b-y-t-i-a-j-e-n-n-a on instagram and
there's an email it's where you can uh
place your orders guys yes i'm the one
that told her get a [ __ ] sticker with
a label make it look real cute and she
did finally yeah esther was like come to
me when you want to be real about this
we should give her do you like money
yeah you guys thank you so much for
joining us on the special episode of our
podcast slash
youtube show whatever you want to call
it
trash bag of slugs um i'm so happy that
people finally got to have see jenna on
because i know jenna has a lot of fans
we reference you so much yeah people and
i'm also so happy for the people who
don't know jenna yet and now know that
she's insane she's one of us she's a
celebrity she's a slug she's the og slug
she's a busy slug though busy bodied
[ __ ] always busy bodied it's like
whatever and i highly recommend
following her i feel like there's so
much everyone can learn from her
y'all are so sweet
bye guys see you next week
you